is that flatter bubbly
it's a bunch of bourbon in here
no it's um
it's flat because i thought i'm like yo
mama oh
[Music]
i'm talking eight cups my man
i'm sorry i don't know where that guy
your mom is she has huge breasts
your mom is very well endowed thank you
this is a this is a huge crowd and like
you go to like the tonight show in the
states and there's like five people in
the audience
that's only when you're there
peter i just want to get one final
thought from you are there words that
are used to describe men that offend you
uh not particularly and if there were
some i don't like i certainly wouldn't
want them banned but it go you know it
always goes back to that old adage
sticks and stones may break my bones but
there will always be something to offend
a feminist
no that's just abnormalities
that is ridiculous that no hang on i
won't do your show again if you don't
let me respond
but here i want you to know something
because uh she's a huge fan of yours but
there's an opening right now for you
because the top you're not the top the
top is always for my mom daniel
day-lewis but i'm just saying if you
keep up your high-quality work i feel
like you could hit that new pinnacle for
my mom oh really yeah
again just joking
a year ago
you told me
on my radio show the audio and the
transcript are out there on youtube that
you would release your tax returns so
you're going back on your no first of
all very few people listen to your radio
show that's the good news let me just
wanted a tattoo on your penis i wanted
to put a tattoo if i would get one there
that would say buyer beware
what are you gonna say i'm impressed
there's enough room i tell you wow
and i can assure you
that he knows there is
like one of my the biggest parts of my
life if that even makes sense um i have
what i used to call a super sniffer you
guys watch psych when you're little
because i love that show i watched it
when i was little
african-american rappers sing inward
this and inward that but a caucasian
can't so say it
say what
say the word you want to say i'm not
saying that i want to say it i'm just
saying that i can't so you can say it
say it right now
i will say it with you okay are you the
kind of m character in the film who
gives them the secret weapons yeah i
suppose i am there's a bit of love
interest going in there um there was
there was a moment actually um
in the film where um i i cop a feel of
his man boob
you might want to translate that for the
american audience
means i suppose it means you put your
hand on his gentleman's
upstairs breast peck area yeah yes his
pectoral muscle his pectoralis yes i i
gently stroke who's the gentleman with
whose man boob you fell chris evans who
plays captain america i don't think he i
don't think he has man boobs though he's
got firm chestly areas they were
absolutely enormous though i mean um
you know coming from you that's a hell
of a thing to
say why'd you ask him if he had a rap
name you didn't ask me if i had it
no you have a rap name m c squared
you're the one i've seen in my dreams
you wanna hear the course no i couldn't
hear anymore okay
best singer in america oh yeah right i
can honestly say you are the worst
singer in america
truthfully that's my first audition well
i'm not surprised it should be your last
that way
uh nicki minaj or cardi b
you want to pass you want to pass
there's a reason that women live longer
mark let me tell you it is because we
are stronger and we are happier at the
end of the day than most men and that is
factual and you know it
when when men are married to women who
scream like you they just want to die
sooner
when you have any when you have women
going around my doctor says you are fat
i said how fat am i
he said you're so fat that uh if you
don't stop within a month you could have
a heart attack or stroke that's not
funny
he's not a comedian no
i was expecting a joke you're expecting
a joke yeah it sounds like yours my
cardiologist
um you're five
hours late here
shut the [ __ ] up come on man no we just
saw you on twitter
about five hours late [ __ ] i'm here and
they could be happy i'm here and ask
some real questions yeah i was just
wondering what you what you know why you
were so late and i saw you were
twittering about stop me being stuffed
at the porter i was late because i went
to go get some chicken wings that's why
i was late
i'd be happier i'm not i can't turn up
to your i can't turn up to your lecture
i'm a mother with a successful career
i'm very happy for you that's wonderful
i think you made a great choice i think
motherhood is awesome you should have as
many babies as you want and not get
bullied by feminists for it no
which many of them do now they're
women's studies
i had as many children as i wanted and
i've got a career so i'm not sure what
you're you're telling me that was wrong
i i think feminism as as piers has been
discussing here or hinting at i think
feminism has collapsed into rampant
sexist man-hating bigotry and female
supremacism
that's what these hashtags toxic
masculinity the future is female i'm not
female where's my future
[Music]
[Music]
actual customer out here uh what's uh
what's the best kind of firework to buy
wouldn't you like to know weatherboy
where are your parents
bruce caitlyn jenner i'll call him
caitlyn jenner no it's her you're not
being polite to the pronoun because
disrespect okay forget about the
disrespect facts don't care about your
feelings it turns out that every
chromosome every cell in caitlyn
jenner's body is male with the exception
of some of his sperm cells you cut that
out now or you'll go home in an
ambulance
yeah that seems mildly inappropriate for
a political discussion you're a poor
man's mike myers
you're so old when you were a kid
rainbows were black and white
i'm a first amendment absolutist i
believe in only two things completely
the first amendment and boobs and so
once they made the decision what did you
say you believe in the first amendment
and
bwbs
boobs two things that have only never
let me down in this entire country's
history the first amendment and boobs so
those are the only two things i believe
in absolutely in the country watch this
particular piece of video uh
what's what's nice
what's nice about this time is the fact
that iron mike tyson who you heard
earlier talking about the
nets
also had a chance to look at this video
and here it is mike's analysis i love
this
that was just really funny yeah that was
really funny
don't fight if you if that's not what
you do just don't do it check with a
little awkward a little hesitant you
know hesitating and throwing the punch
and they didn't come across as good
fighters you know
and by the way chuck
i will kick your ass you know i would i
would just kick your ass i will kick
your ass
kick it
okay
okay
let me look the camera forward
mike tyson
there's this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board
oh
all right do something with that you
freak
i i bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d